à la coupe 26 la Conférence des Nations
Unies sur le climat des pays ne
s'entendent pas sur un des points
principaux de la corde de Paris de 2015
limitez l'augmentation moyenne de la
planète à 1,5 degrés oh
considérés à l'époque comme une avancée
majeure dans la lutte au réchauffement
climatique cet objectif pourrait bien
être exclu de la résolution finale
secrétaire d'État sous l'administration
de Barack Obama aimerait bien qu'il en
soit autrement
en conférence de presse John curry
souligne que l'Egypte le pays haute du
sommet de la COP 27 n'a pas l'intention
d'être considéré comme le pays du recul
par rapport au dernier sommet sur le
climat à Glasgow en Écosse
[Applaudissements]
en 2015 dans le cadre de l'accord de
Paris les gouvernements du monde entier
s'étaient entendu pour tenter de limiter
l'augmentation moyenne de la température
mondiale à 1,5 degrés Celsius
il en va de la santé de la planète et
des générations futures selon cette
ancien médecin venu de la Tanzanie on
voit que les négociations s'intensifient
c'est normal d'avoir ce genre d'essai de
la part de pays qui veulent diluer
l'accord le 1.5 degré et là pour rester
restera là et on espère évidemment que
ça valait beaucoup plus loin dans les
engagements des pays la cop27 se termine
le 18 novembre d'ici là il y a encore
lieu d'espérer que les pays parviennent
à un accord incluant la cible de 1,5
degrés ici Gabriel prout Radio-Canada
Montréal